tous les pays où je viens et j'ai
posé des questions sur les règles ici et les locaux
m'ont confirmé que je peux m'adresser comme
d'habitude parce que pour la Coupe du monde, ils
font une exception et je n'ai pas
eu de mauvaise réaction comme je vous l'ai dit,
les katari en arabe  les gens viennent me voir
pour faire euh des photos avec moi même de très belles
femmes et femmes sur le stade lors du
dernier match elles sont venues la photo est aussi devenue
virale avec un joli hijab et elles sont venues me voir
pour faire des photos avec moi dans ma
tenue de création de tenue mais  J'ai eu dans le dernier
match et je pense que c'est incroyable de
s'accepter d'être différent
[Applaudissements]
d'accord